hey roger how's it going hey martin not
bad how are you
ah sweating it out here with this
heatwave we have here in mountain music
yeah man i'm feeling it too it's a
little warm out today
it is those are some cool dog photos
behind you where
where are they from ah these are just
some uh some of the few shots i've taken
over the years i do some dog photography
sometimes
so i just like to put my favorite shots
on the wall oh here we are
cool that gives me an idea we've had
several viewers have actually asked in
the youtube comments
if we could create a build a rest api
serverless rest api with a serverless
compute and a serverless database
maybe we could have a rest api that
tells you about
dog breeds that is a very good idea and
i think we should use
a firestore back end how does that sound
sounds great let's do it
all right roger so i went ahead and
created a
project here in google cloud platform
called dog breed api
good name yeah and our database uh
was firestore right yep
let's jump to the firestore and
um for your instructions i created
a dog's collection and let's see what
are we looking at here
so collection in the firestore world is
pretty much a table
and in that table we're gonna have
different entries which are gonna be
documents
so we have a table dogs and we have one
document there i see and it has
four fields life expectancy a name
origin
and a type so we have one breed
in our database so far and that breed is
still mission looks like yes and every
breed will have one document so the cool
thing is that
we have these four fields but we're not
it's not just those four we can always
add more fields if we need to in the
future
but for now i think we're cool with just
life expectancy name origin and type
okay very good so then we need to put a
rest
api in front of this so i guess we'll
jump over to code
i set up uh before uh our
call here today i set up a bare bones
node application and imported
uh the firestore client library in the
express library
yep and express is just going to serve
as our http server that's going to
respond to
our get requests and give us the
dog breed information that we want very
good and then i
added start here that will tell the
container
or tell the thing running our container
to
you execute this container by executing
node
with index.js as the parameter exactly
so
now that you mention it index.js let's
check that out
all right i put a little bit of code in
here this is sort of a
bare bones rest api right
yep not much happening right now except
for the bare minimum
we are starting our http server and it's
listening to port 8080
and we'll know that because they'll
console log that nice little listening
line there on line nine and then it's
going to respond to any
get requests to the root with a bark
bark raider roll status message
in a json object so let's just test that
out real quick just to make sure we're
not
messing things up npm start yeah
look at that we got this far
now how do we get to this part uh we
either go to a browser but
to make it quick just jump to another
terminal window and curl localhost 8080.
oops let's see
hey look at that
but nothing is happening yet with
firestore but you'll see on line two
that we have the library for firestore
and we're we're bringing it into our
project there and then on line
four we have a new instance of firestore
which is going to use
our application default credentials to
access the firestore associated with our
project
oh that's so cool yeah we don't online
for here we don't really need a password
or connection string or anything right
right once this gets built into a
container and run on cloud run
it's just going to use some application
default credentials which will use a
service account to run
what needs to run to access our
firestore very nice
okay so we'll start with our app get we
already have an
app get for the root but now we have an
app get for
colon breed and that colon breed is
going to refer to a variable
for for example dalmatian and it's going
to run this asynchronous function
as you can see we're going to make a
variable breed and it's going to take
that breed
value from from the url and then we're
going to construct a query
so the query's not doing anything now
we're just constructing it right now
and it's going to look at the collection
dogs which we saw earlier
where the name is that breed variable
exactly
and now the query snapshot is going to
hold the actual
uh results so it's going to be
asynchronous function
query get
and then we're going to want we're going
to want to be
we're going to tell the user the results
if we have results and tell it that we
don't have results if we don't have
results so
there we have an if statement saying
that if the query snapshot size is
greater than zero which is not
nothing we're going to respond with the
first
document of the data that we we get back
very good yeah we could potentially get
several back but
right we'll just return the first yeah
else we want to respond something nice
like sorry couldn't find it or not found
or
something let the user know that
something is wrong
status how about something like this
not found yes perfect all right very
good
uh there we go
deploy.sh so let's jump to that file and
see what's happening right now
yeah so this is a several part file here
it looks like we just set a variable
here but then there are two pieces
what's this one so we have gcloud
builds which is going to take our code
and build a container out of it with
based on the docker file that we we
provide
in the same directory so it's going to
build that it's going to upload it to
google container registry
and then it's going to go into the
second part of our command which is
going to do cloud run which is going to
deploy
our application based on that image ah
right
so the first part just builds a
container and the second part
starts that contains spins it up so it
can start
serving traffic exactly to get a better
look at this we can jump to
our uh cloud build page
yep there it is
oh it just finished good yep
that one yep click that build
and if something went wrong we would we
would see it here in our build log
so i see a lot of green check boxes
check marks so
yeah that's always a good sign let's
jump to our container registry page yep
very good so here's our barkbark api
yep and here we have one container
that was built just now just now right
on time and you see that latest tag
hit that little pencil next to the
latest we could add other tags so in
this case
it's gonna be version yeah version 1.0
the most dangerous
version of any software yep
and we'll come back to that latest tag
later but for now let's run
let's go to cloud run page on our
content yeah let's see
so cloud run okay this is now we're
actually going to look at
the deployed container not just the list
of built containers but yep there's
barkbark api
and no requests to come in no errors
either
and it looks like we have one version of
the api
yeah and this is where all your
revisions would show up so once we start
building more and more and more
they will all show up here and the cool
thing is that you can direct traffic
to more than one that way if you want to
for example test out a canary build of
something you can do it here
yeah like google does right so do we
deploy a new version
send that new version to one percent of
users then templates
exactly yeah and you have the option of
rolling back if you have to right
so if we click that url up there that is
our application look at that park park
ready to roll it's working here it is
perfect now let's see if it's actually
talking to our firestore
so remember we have that one entry
dalmatian yep yeah
that's that breed variable is going to
be dalmatian and yes
that is our dalmatian information that
we wanted
oh okay and i like poodles
ah not found no poodles for you so it's
not very useful
still we only this is pretty much a
dalmatian information
api it's not serving much information so
we want to do
nothing wrong with that i like
dalmatians but they're like i said
before there's a lot more of more dogs
out there
so what we want to do is is be able to
to use a post
request to add entries to our firestore
to our fire
store um so this is for so that people
can
write create new breeds in our database
exactly yes so similar to our app get
function
from before we're going to have this
times at post for post requests
and yeah slash is fine
yeah and let's cons we're going to
construct our data object
it's going to correspond with the values
the fields in
our document so it's pulling it from the
body of our request so what we're going
to do we're going to make it so that
the post request is sent in a json
format
and we're going to pull the the fields
from that json object
and put it into this data object here
and this is just for readability sake
yeah and expectancy is so hard to spell
did i spell it right
yeah i never spelled that right so you
did pretty good this time all right
yes perfect
okay and here comes our weight line
and similar to before
and our collection again is dogs right
and then it's going to be a new dock so
it's going to be empty and we're going
to set
data all right so we're writing our data
variable
and what are we returning to users so
once that happens we want to respond
a json object that just says that it's
been a success
so yeah there you go success and just to
make sure
that we are what we know we're doing we
want to respond with the object that we
just
sent it so all right
that all looks good to me if it looks
good to you let's deploy it
yep so and we're running the same exact
deploy script as we did before
so it's going to know that this is a new
version of the same container that we
did before
and it's gonna do what it has to do
accordingly um
so while that goes we can jump to the
uh cloud build page on the console
very good cloud build uh
there is cloud build aha
the building you see it's spinning it is
spinning it's going it's running
things are happening right now step two
out of six step
three out of six step four out of six
okay it's getting there
it's getting there five out of six
it should only take another moment but
in the meantime we could jump to the
cloud uh the container registry page
again yep
continue registry
barkbark api our old friend
aha now there are two of them in here
just now
again perfect timing so you see v1 the
one that we just did a little while ago
but you see the latest tag that i
mentioned before
it moved up to the container that we
just uploaded
so now we add another tag to it yeah
what if we call this
uh version 2.0 our dog breed startup is
going very well
five minutes progressing
yeah so the cool thing about the latest
is that you you never have to worry
about updating the latest tag to another
container
and and also the fact that you can use
tags means that you can deploy
different versions of the same container
all right
let's jump in
we'll see them over here i think
so here we are in cloud run cloud run is
actually handling
traffic from users and it looks like we
jumped from
this old version to new one it's zero
percent of traffic is going to the old
one
100 to the new version of this container
yes
exactly so like we mentioned before if
you had to do a canary build you can
always change that traffic
uh percentage that way we're not just
jumping straight to the newest version
100 traffic yeah
okay should we see if we broke anything
let's see if we broke anything
so roger what are the chances that this
will work you think uh
i mean i like breaking things but i
think we did pretty good i
have 90 confidence that this is fine for
once but only this once i'm gonna say
more higher percentage than you 95
percent 95 all right let's see what
happens
all right okay we didn't break that
let's see if we still have our dalmatian
entry uh-huh very good there's our
dalmatian
cool and let's see added what was that
we
so we want to test the post
functionality right so let's jump the
postman yeah
postman excellent piece of software for
uh
testing apis so first
actually i'll just send a real quick
request here with this get just to make
sure everything works
we got the dalmatian back but it's not
yet we're supposed to test here we're
supposed to test
post right yeah
all right so remember we're posing to
the root so yeah just leave the url
blank like that
make sure we have a json object all
right
and let's construct our json object so
again it's going to correspond with the
fields
of the documents yeah what breed should
we add to our breeds data base you think
let's go with beagle bee
that's correct yep all right uh where do
beagles come from
beagles come from england england all
right
and nope that was not it
live i was hoping i wouldn't have to
spell out life exactly
nice try yeah oh so i forgot the quotes
all right how do how long do beagles
live uh 13
13 a little longer than dalmatians
and then type so beagles are famously
known as being a scent
dog dog they are really good smellers
they can smell things
really good all right so post we post to
the root
of this api we send this json along so
this should add it to the
database let's hit it it should it
should
let's see if it does
it's taking quite a while yeah let's
check it out let's see what's going on
here
yeah fortunately everything goes into
the logs
let's see here uh-huh looks like a juicy
error here
uh type dbcollection.db
collection dot docs this
is not a function all right let's look
in the code
let's check that out db collection
dogs oh stupid yes stuck
ah all right just don't
say it again yeah so just to
take this as a learning moment here
we're
taking this collection which is kind of
like a table
and this piece here is creating a one
new document so like an empty document
in that table and this piece here
sets the data uh so sets this data for
this new
empty document exactly so now we can
just rerun that same
deploy script again so it's again it's
going to know exactly
uh what container to
upload this to on the container registry
so we jump back to container registry
and by the way uh just one more thing
here we are doing we're running this
gcloud commands
interactively here as developers right
if you're in a larger situ
organization you would typically have
this at the end of a ci cd
pipeline where your csd tool would run
something along those lines
for example checking some something to
the master branch
yeah and that pipeline might have some
type of code review where they might
pick up on
typos yeah we just saw so humans or
machines that
uh that look at your code yeah yes
correct
all right all right so it looks like it
finished so let's try that again let's
just go straight into the post and see
if we can yeah
let's see if this works
we got something oh look at that he's
got something success
that is our success message that we
asked it to
respond with so it looks like it worked
but let's make absolutely sure that it
did work
yeah so i'll do a get to hit
oh i should not send a body along with
that right
there we go oh all right there's our
beagle the beagle so i guess
the beagles in the database i don't
believe you
show me show me that's right only one
way to make sure
spinning spinning spinning
i see dogs i see two documents i see
dalmatian and now
the one that's yeah
all right so now it's a lot easier to
enter
all the dogs your heart desires and not
have to do it manually
sitting there and everything here was
serverless
cloud run is serverless you don't have
to deal with setup and maintaining
servers
and scaling up and down and firestore is
serverless so you don't have to deal
with planning capacity
beautiful very good if you have any
questions about anything we built here
or any questions or requests for other
videos that we
should shoot about serverless computing
please let us know in the comments
[Music]
you